- Can't believe it's come to this...
- Hi, I'm Najee,
and I'm an underperforming fantasy player.
- Hi, Najee.
- I mean, what does Magic Johnson know
about winning, anyway?
- I told y’all. I don't belong here.
I was a Pro Bowler!
- [Carr:] Me too!
- [Tannehill:] Me too!
- Say it with me, everyone:
- Nobody cares about the Pro Bowl.
- Welcome.
And believe it or not,
I used to be just like you.
I once got benched for John Wolford.
- [GASPS]
- It's true.
But now, I'm a straight baller.
- [SNAPS]
- Hey, I'm just blue collar Kenny Pickett.
Just a lunch pail and jeans fella that was
lucky enough to make it out of the Pitt.
Lost a lot of good men lately, Diontae...Cam.
But hey, that's just life,
down at the steel yard.
- I don't trust myself to leave home because
that's the only place I can perform.
- I took too much money from some men you do NOT want to upset,
and now I'm getting all sorts of threats.
- So we pull up to this club in Ibiza-
- Jimmy, we're supposed to talk
about our struggles.
- Oh, am I struggling?
- I used to be Joe Sheisty.
I thought I was invincible.
But then, you know, you get hammered
in Cleveland once and it becomes a habit.
Next thing you know,
you're getting blown out by the Titans.
- Hey!
- Tell me Sheisty, are you a praying man?
- You know you can't let people down
if everyone thinks you're just a lil stinker.
- It's just for so long
I've acted really cool all the time.
And sometimes Joe Burrow hurts.
- Joe Burrow?!
- [Jimmy G:] Bill Skarsgard?!
- I'm struggling,
and I don't know what to do.
- Oh, you play the Cardinals.
- Hey, Joe. I need a ride
home from my hot seat meeting.
- I grew up with small town American values.
Sock hop on a Friday. Church on Sunday.
But all that's gone now.
Down in the trenches, the American way is dead.
Instead,
it's the Canada way.
The Matt Canada way.
And it makes no sense to me at all.